Canaris yeah well she is fine she asked
if I would talk about the change in the
show from Jeyne Westerling to it Tulisa
of Beaumont us um the first up shot of
that was Richard Madden I mean we had
his wonderful actor Richard met and he
done a great job playing Rob stark and
if you look at the book you know Rob is
there read in the beginning and then he
leads his army west and when he's gone
in fact book I mean we find out what's
happening this occasionally a raven
arrives and you know cat gets a report
that the Rob has won another battle in
the West and David then I think rightly
felt that it would be very foolish to
you know not see Richard Madden for an
entire season and not equally foolish
there are their practical kind of
purpose their agents of that I mean what
if you pay him you pay an actor for an
entire season to work and don't use him
that's a waste of money and every money
is necessary but if you don't pay him
and just expect a mire of back of third
sees and then maybe takes you 12 with
someone else and then when you turn
around any one iron back he's no longer
available because he's now on the tutors
or something
ladies a terrific young actor so we
didn't want to do that so the first
decision was the decision made that we
would keep we would show Rob we would
follow wrong and we would show what he
was doing in Westwood he was separated
from from Catalan in the books and then
at some point David then also made the
decision that they wouldn't have him you
know I have this the relationship on
screen with the woman that he will
definitely marry and but they made
changes who her my story would really be
that they have so about it not quite
sure I guess they just thought there was
a more interesting character
my contribution when I got that I looked
at they make her a noblewoman from
volantis and then all of this stuff and
I said well okay but don't hold her Jane
anymore Jane is not a Bolin time name if
you're going to change the character so
completely and not make her daughter
vanished at Bannerman marry her instead
of this healer from volantis you have to
give her a Holden team name instead of
just being changed so I saw in it that
sense I changed the name there we are
yeah okay so in regarding various little
birds
the conversation keeps landing does he
have their tongues cut out now there's
some evidence yes not that he does it
himself they're provided to him in that
session the decline of the Nights Watch
is that's something that the Meister who
wrote the world of Ice and Fire is
that's something he talks about or are
they even aware of a federation where it
but the you know the whole question is
is something this is a knife weren't
even necessary and it's necessary how
big of force is necessary you know those
who have lost the faith that there's
anything out there besides the wildlings
I don't think it needs to be very big
why should it be very big this butchered
savages who come occasionally and you
know steal horses and women and you know
we food and then runs back so you don't
need a whole army to fight them you know
but of course you and I know that the
side there may be a little more to worry
about then they assume a
what did Littlefinger deuteron Roberts
were betting enough probably not a whole
couple o'clock
he was probably back on his own land I
mean he had been wounded
you know quite seriously in his duel
with Brandon Stark only shortly before
that and he was actually close to death
there took a long time to recover and
you know then I got thrown out because
Hospital they didn't like him you know
fooling around with them with their
daughters yes back by the wall the
Cataclysm in the in the Song of Ice and
Fire the changes is an explanation of
that
thanks for what
there could be whatever Cataclysm caused
the change of this so that there yeah
kind of sort of you know it's a fantasy
so I get letters all the time from
people trying to work it out as in their
science fiction show that's given the
triple star system one that asses you
know etc and occasionally a sample that
comes through in the Train know